俺は今まで数々のドッキリをしてきたらたぶん今回が本当に一番をスムーズと思ってい
ますとは出してる人がしてがそれに行くんですけど
今日そいつよねー
ドッキリで
ちょっとば背中ないです
今までよくゴキブリの土中で打っていったんですけどもう今日はもう
ゴキブリをね100匹買いました
黒ピットのならはからキャッツ市が笑えないレベルだと
うわぁやるよねやべやべやですこれやべぇこれ
やばいよ出身したよ
なんか回ん
[音楽]
これを仕掛けたいんだすべきであるとタイミングとしてはデラックスけど俺ん家に入っ
てきて
入ってきて
そのトイレにもう仕掛けるですよ先にトイレに仕掛けて
を入れることは木出すんだぐ居飛車 p が待って言って作品です
うーん
本当にヤバイ奴をた場所になんでん
それから仕掛けてきます
に本当にこれ発表するんじゃないかな
ん
ですできました
どうでしょう
セッティングはもうこんなもんでいいと思うんですけどねここにデラックス君が入るの
を待とうと思いますでレックスがグーノームなっちゃいます
家極上中央
あってが来たっ
エロいぞデラックス月桃色さあどう悶絶ですはいアイバーさーいないどうぞ
じゃあ私は最賃チクップレゼンライン出すのサーブやもっと1 d 4型じゃ
いやー初めてニョはこれ
つだけで半紙トイレに行ってきてください分かった
レッツたの
何もに妻には方飼っ
盗まんから入って来
ちゃんってと仮定
これやったらそう言うなと言い妻ようん
萌えっとねハッセルみた動画本当に見たんだよ
どうかありがとうさらに大バイ
ん
ロンダート見せたり前期は真ん中 ok
溺愛ますか
元で約村スローよしっ
某沿いガッツキンっ
いっ
[音楽]
dj
井垣ソース殺しません
立ってもう活活しますいやだやだ部分を得ちょっとマジかよ